Before we import our first project,
let's take a peek at
what we just downloaded.
You'll see a ton of folders.
Each one contains a LibGDX project
that's either some demo code,
the starting point of an exercise,
or our solution to an exercise.
That's right.
All the answers to the coding exercises
are right here in the course code,
just means we can give you
a tougher problems, right?
Each folder is numbered by
where it goes in the course.
So the demo code for
the first lesson, second level,
which is what we're doing right now,
is in 1.2.
If we open up this folder,
it looks like there's a ton
of different files in here.
But just staring at this file list for
a moment,
the word that pops out is gradle?
Let's see there's build.gradle,
gradle.properties, a gradle folder,
a bunch of other stuff.
What is this gradle thing?
I thought we were working with LibGDX?